I had a period of time
after my divorce where I was
really ambitious when it came to women
but then that it felt like a job like it
felt like a job after a while where I
was like God it's like enough it's kind
of enough you know like it's like it's
like when you've eaten so much that you
just feel like yeah I got that way with
[__] like it really was like I just had
enough like it was fine I was like this
is great but well when you're in your
20s or 30s maybe yeah yeah your libido
is a strong meal it's actually insane
yeah yeah I was not I definitely was we
age we mellow yeah which I think is
great although I have to tell you one of
the most depressing divorces I ever did
was a guy who was I think 92. oh geez
and what made it depressing is that he
had left his wife of I don't know 50
something 60 something years for a
younger woman a woman in her 50s
and I just remember what was sad about
it to me was this guy is still being led
around by his deck like I thought oh my
God like I'm gonna be chained to an
idiot forever like I'm gonna forever be
led around by my dad and I remember
thinking like no I really thought that
at like 90 something I would just like a
beautiful woman would walk by and I go
oh there's a human being like there
would be no appreciated without yeah
there would just be no sense of like
yeah you know there would just that
would be gone from me and this guy's
proof that 90 something years old and
you're still thinking with your deck
like I we're doomed that terrified me it
really did it actually upset me because
I thought man I thought at some point
I'd get to experience what it's like to
just be free if you live in New York
where there's there's a financial
industry there's oh yeah there's all
kinds of Industries here oh yeah but to
me sometimes I I wonder if female
attractiveness isn't the mo the highest
valued commodity 100 it is 100 it is
yeah yeah of course because men are
becoming rich and Powerful in order to
get a woman of course the woman they
want of course what a what an attractive
woman and when I say attractive I don't
just mean attractive I I mean even just
sexually confident I mean what an
unbelievably lucrative career that is
like I do divorces for people that you
know a woman walks out with two 300
million dollars he was an analyst at
Goldman Sachs who built a hedge fund and
then sold it and then used his trading
algorithm to build it up to 500 million
dollars she was hot
and slept with him for a while and then
stopped and started sleeping with other
people and playing tennis and having
Botox and she's going to get half like
that's [__] incredible like you know
what he had to do to get that and what
she had I'll [__] that guy for 200
million dollars are you kidding me like
that's insane that's incredible like and
what and God bless I mean I'm not saying
that this person this is the rules of
the game you know but you can't argue
that that's not easier than going to
Harvard no for sure but then but then
the payoff the trade-off for that is
that when they hit a certain age the
value right any stock if you hold it too
long it's going to go down you know like
so play play the stock the right way I
mean and that's what I think if we were
a little more honest about the nature of
male female coupling I mean right now we
can't even you know we can't even
establish what is gender you know we
can't establish any of that anymore so
so divorce is becoming incredibly
hilarious and fraught but to me what
what is
like sometimes you have to stand back
and look at things to get the real
perspective on what it is and
sometimes you look back at marriage so
when was it invented like 2000 BC
roughly
in the life expectancy of humans back
then was 18 years old yeah and yeah
marriage was created for
um land ownership land ownership and
things like that yeah and if you're
going to die in your early 20s or
whatever then then getting married at 16
18 makes sense well I think there's a
distinction that has to be made between
pair bonds
and marriage right marriage is a is a is
a government concept marriage is a
contract marriage is a legal status
pair bonds right two people
go in it together you know saying hey
there's 7.3 billion people in the world
and the two of us we're gonna we're
gonna lock up together and we're gonna
try to hold hands and get through this
thing until we're eight years old well
until whatever you know I mean what's
interesting is first of all marriages
end they end in death are divorced but
they all end like every marriage ends so
it's one of the only things that you go
wow I really hope this ends in US dying
you know most things you you that's not
the desired outcome but in marriage you
hope marriage will end in death you hope
that you will be together until one or
both of you die you know but all
marriages end so as a guy as a provider
if you knew it was going to end and you
were going to have to give away half
your money you you might think twice
about doing it well I think that's what
makes being a divorce lawyer interesting
is that it's it's a lot of what a court
has to do is disregard what happened in
the marriage because a the truth is at
the bottom of a bottomless pet like
you're never going to get there yeah
well I was he's [__] his secretary
right because you were not sleeping with
me anymore I have a client whose wife
acknowledges she didn't sleep with him
for six years what what did you think
was going on if you didn't sleep with
him for six years so yeah okay don't
delegate you've delegated that
responsibility if you don't want to have
sex with him that's okay no one should
force you to have sex with this person
let him go have sex with someone else
you don't want to do the laundry hire
someone to do the laundry if you don't
want to mow your own lawn hire someone
to mow the lawn delegate that
responsibility and this guy wasn't even
sleeping around he was going to those
hand job places you know where you get a
massage you get like what the most
pathetic thing in the world the most
innocuous thing in the world he didn't
have a girlfriend there was no love
involved he was getting jacked off for
fifty dollars like that's sad like I
mean first of all hand jobs like that's
an outdated technology that's like a
betamax you know like who even does that
anymore but he he was doing this and he
just thought okay that's fine she had
the indignation to say he is not a good
he shouldn't be a custodial parent he's
a terrible person because he's doing
this
and it was like wait how is that that
much different than going to a strip
club how is that much more different
because we just you know he was like
well should I deny it and I was like is
it true and he's like well yeah I said
no we should own it let's go in and say
yeah you know what yeah it's pathetic
it's really pathetic my wife didn't
sleep with me for six years and I'm
human
and I wanted to have sex still I didn't
want to blow up my life I didn't want to
screw up my kids and have my kids have
divorced parents so I thought all right
she's clearly not interested in me and
more I'm not going to have a girlfriend
and get caught up in all the things
where people could get hurt and there's
feelings and Fatal Attraction and stuff
I'm just gonna go it'll be transactional
like going to a strip club or anything
else and I'm yeah it's a little pathetic
that I'm a guy who makes a million
dollars a year in finance and I'm paying
someone fifty dollars to jack me off
yeah that's kind of pathetic but you
know what I figured out but to suggest
that that means I'm a bad parent that
has nothing to do with my parenting at
all period you know so and thankfully
the judge agreed with me on that one but
I I really do think that that the idea
I don't think I mean if you break it
down fundamentally 56 of marriages end
in divorce but think about that's the
ones that end in divorce so how many
people what percentage stay together for
the kids
or because they don't want to give away
half their [__] another 10 that's
conservative conservative but let's say
let's say 20 then okay you now have a
technology that fails 76 of the time
that's insane that's insane that's more
likely than not 76 if I tell you there's
a 76 chance when you walk out the door
today you're gonna get hit in the head
with a bowling ball you would not go out
or you'd wear a helmet for sure but
people just continue to get married not
only do they continue to get married
there's a presumption
that you should get married and if you
don't get married there's something
wrong with you so if you've got a
girlfriend and you've been with her for
five years and you say to someone we're
getting married they go oh that's great
you know they don't go why you're happy
why would you get married like
everything's going fine why would you
put yourself through that why would you
run that risk if you say to someone
we've been together five years and we've
decided we're not going to get married
we're going to move in together but
we're not going to get married ooh
what's wrong yeah intimacy issues what's
your problem meanwhile set 56 end in
divorce it's it's literally fits the
legal definition of negligence it's a
negligent Behavior the way you Define
negligence in law school is when what
you lose by not doing something okay is
lower than the risk of harm it's what's
called a BPL analysis so the burden of
not doing a thing is lower than the
likelihood the probability
of harm so BPL it's a burden probability
and loss
marriage is an inherently negligent
activity it's like owning a lion like
it's it's it you're the likelihood of
someone getting hurt seriously is very
very high no one ever says it to you
because why because
and I'm I would say something I've been
doing this for over 20 years and I I
still get misty-eyed at weddings like I
still really there's something in me
that goes like you know maybe it'll work
out for these two sweet I absolutely
believe in love I think love is
wonderful the but love and marriage have
very little to do with each other I
don't think there's much of a
correlation there I I think that's where
we got off track like I believe in pair
bonds I believe I don't think I can
learn everything I need to know about
myself from myself
I think having someone around you sees
my blind spots and that doesn't have to
be a romantic partner that could be a
friend that could be any number of
things but there is something wonderful
about romantic connection we know that I
mean the other statistic is 56 percent
of marriage is sent in divorce but 84 of
people who get divorced are remarried
within five years of their divorce
really let's think about that so now
you've now you've done it
and failed and felt the pain of the loss
and within five years 84 are remarried
so when you fall in love
and you're you're with a partner who's
in love with you it's just it's like
hard to put the brakes on and say you
know what that's as far as I'm gonna go
well I think we you know whoever
discovered what or it wasn't a fish and
I think when we're in a thing we don't
see it and so I mean and this is true
there must be some endorphins some some
something's being released in our brains
listen you want to test that theory the
next time you're out with a couple
who've been together for a while and it
like seems like they maybe got in a
fight or they're just like kind of being
you know impatient with each other at
the table you know when you go like a
group thing
just say to them so tell me about how
you met
tell me tell me the story of how you met
and everything on them changes like they
go back to that place and there's this
like oh yeah and she was this because
for that second you go back to that
place like you can go someone with a
horrible divorce
if you could get them to go to that
place and talk to you about that time
like I I would say something when I was
a kid
you know like every kid you have the
fantasy of like if you were invisible
what would you do you didn't go to the
girl's locker room you know whatever I I
have this fantasy that if I could be
invisible I I have about eight clients
that I'd like to sneak into their house
and find their wedding album like I know
it's in the Attic somewhere or something
because I would love to see what it
looked like when these people loved each
other because they are weaponized
against each other now and we are trying
to kill each other and we're taking
every secret every intimacy everything
at their ugliest at their ugliest at
their worst and there's something in me
that just the thought that like you guys
at some point like at some point you
were like they're 7.3 billion people in
the world and you're the one like you're
the one I just want to be with and smell
and touch and like that that feeling we
all know that feeling of like just the
electricity of another person you know
and and I I mean I you know I I think
I'm romantic at hard in the sense that I
really get it like I really get why we
do this I I felt it I know it I
understand it but
tying that to the technology of marriage
to me makes almost no sense whatsoever
and I actually think it's almost
antagonistic
to that connection with another person
because there's so much expectation that
comes with marriage culturally we've
created so much stuff around it like
when you when you marry someone they're
supposed to be
at least in the modern Western model
your best friend best roommate best
co-parent best travel partner best uh
roommate best everything best activity
partner like how how would one person be
all of those things that's insane like
if if I if I was interviewing for a job
and said I want you to be the best
typist and I also want you to be best on
the phone and I also want you to be
great at it and I ran down a list of
dissimilar things like or if I went to
an amazing chef and I said I know you're
a great chef but can you farm like well
that has to do with food but they're not
the same thing like what are you talking
so I think why do we put on people this
idea like whoever came up with the word
soulmate
really we should be paying like divorce
lawyers should be paying that person
dividends because we've convinced people
that if this person isn't meeting every
one of your needs checking all of these
boxes they're not your soulmate your
soul mate would know exactly what to do
exactly what to say at exactly the right
time
I can get I can go off on this stuff
yeah I tend to wait what do you think
the secret is just keeping a marriage
vital keeping it a lot you know I think
I think
people
get unhappy in marriages the way that
people go bankrupt which is very slowly
and then all at once
I think it's very slow and then it just
goes off a cliff so everybody will say
well we divorced because he was cheating
or she was cheating or we divorced
because he had an alcohol issue or drug
issue which lately we're seeing more
like alcohol and drugs is is a big big
thing especially post pandemic there's a
tremendous amount of substance abuse
stuff that's causing a lot of issues in
marriages
and certainly like social media has
increased the accessibility of adultery
and connections to other people and
reconnections with people from your past
who remind you of a version of yourself
that you felt more excited about because
you were younger so it's you know it
used to be if you like ran into the girl
you banged in high school
it was like once every 10 years a
reunion you know or if you lived in the
same town as you grew up in you know you
might run into the person at the Walmart
but now it's like on Facebook you have
all these excuses to be able to chit
chat with someone and all these benign
entry points you know of like oh you
know I saw your pictures from vacation
where did you stay in Miami you know and
and then it becomes oh yeah well you
looked great I mean boy you look
fantastic in a bikini and then all of a
sudden We're Off to the Races and we're
chatting with each other so I I you know
if we were going to invent like an
infidelity machine you couldn't do
better than Facebook and Instagram I
mean that's about as good as it gets but
I I genuinely think that the secret
to staying happy in a marriage is
probably
the the same secret to maintaining a
healthy weight
you know don't wait till you get super
fat and then try to lose the weight
don't wait until you get released like
my sister is a dentist
and she always says if you have a
toothache there's nothing I can do
really like I can pull the tooth I can
give you a root canal but like I can
prevent you from getting a toothache if
you just come see me regularly and you
just floss and you just brush your teeth
you'll never get it to you by the time
your tooth hurts something is already
seriously wrong by the time you're in a
divorce lawyer's office you're [__]
the whole thing's [__] at that point
like you'd be better off
just you know figuring out the
preventative maintenance right like
change the oil in your car like so I
what I try to if you reverse engineer
divorce like most people the marriage
killer you know the the cheating or the
gambling or the whatever that's the
symptom like the the the problem is
these little disconnections you know one
of the one of the
one of the best stories I I have is my I
had a client who I did her divorce and
we'd spend a lot of time together
because you do you know when your
divorce lawyer you spend a lot of time
with people and you get to know them
very well I mean people lie to their
therapists they won't lie to their
divorce lawyer because hey there's no
reason to and B they you know I need to
know everything and it's all
attorney-client privilege and this woman
we were sitting outside the courtroom
waiting on a break in testimony
and she was a young woman in her in her
probably like late 30s you know
very attractive and we were just chit
chatting and I said to her you know was
there a moment
when you realized
the marriage is over
you know like was there a moment
and she said yeah yeah and I said when
was it and she said I there was this
granola that I like she said it I I they
only sold it at like this particular
grocery store and I like to put it in my
yogurt and she said he used to always
whenever I'd be running low on it I
would just open the thing one day and a
new bag would be there she's like and I
I just she's like it made me feel so
loved like he didn't I didn't have to
ask
he didn't want credit for it like he
didn't go like oh did you see I got your
granola that you wanted you know like he
just would do this thing you know and
she said it was just something that like
I just it always made me smile she said
every time the granola was running low
and there was a new bag of granola I
just felt very loved you know and she
said one day the granola ran out
and I thought oh that's weird you know
maybe maybe he didn't see it she's like
so I left the bag in there because I
thought well at some point he'll notice
and he didn't notice
she goes so I took the bag out
and I waited
and he didn't get a new bag
and I thought okay this thing's going
down
and I thought to myself wow that's like
you know that's such a small thing like
granola like you just but but these are
the things like these are the little
things that make us feel loved and that
are gestures of love and I said to her
was there anything like that for you
with him and she said yeah blow jobs
um
and I almost spit out my coffee
and she goes no she goes when we were
first dating and even first married
she's like I used to give [__] a lot
she's like you know she's like do it in
the morning took two minutes and he was
like super happy the rest of the day you
know she's like the rest of the day he
would like call me or text me and be
like Oh I'm so good this morning you
know I had such pep in my step now and
she's like it was just like what did it
really take out of my life to do that
you know and it made him feel good she's
like and then I got to a point where I
was like well you know what no I'll wait
and then tonight we can both have we can
have sex and we'll both enjoy that like
what do I owe him a [__] like no you
know like I don't owe him that you know
and and and then she said I got to a
point where I was like I look back and
I'm like yeah I guess I I didn't do that
as often hardly ever really you know
which came first
you know I said that to her and she said
I I she said I couldn't tell you she
said but I think it's the same thing
it's the same thing and I do think it's
the same thing and I'm not saying
[__] and granola is all you need to
know but and I'm not by the way I'm not
saying that that a [__] is a small
thing I don't think I have any right to
I've never given one but it seems like a
phenomenal feat and I I'm grateful for
everyone I've ever received but I don't
I I don't think it's a massive
investment right just like buying
someone's granola is not a mess she's
like when you love somebody you love
doing things for them right their
pleasure
their Joy pleases you like their their
you know their happiness
makes you happy exactly and somewhere
along the line
and it happens a lot in marriage
it becomes well I'm not happy why should
you be happy you know and then that
creates a spiral and I really believe
that you can that spiral could go in the
other direction like if he did the
granola I think the [__] would have
come you know and if like I and if the
[__] were there I bet he'd have
bought the granola like I I can't prove
that there's no control group you know I
can't run that research but it feels to
me like those little things like like
leaving a note you know I've said to
some of my my friends you know when they
say to me like you know as a divorce
lawyer you see all this misery like
what's how do I stay out of your office
and I'll often say I'm like it's dumb
little things man I'm like just leave
her a note I'm like leave her a note in
the morning just leave a little note
says hey beautiful you know so it was so
fun watching that movie with you last
night so glad we got to have a date I'll
be thinking to you today love you like
what is that tank that takes like a
minute not even like and look what it
can do like look at look at how that
makes this person feel and even if right
away it doesn't work on that moment it
doesn't work okay do it enough times
like and and then you're either gonna
figure out that this person's gone and
then just [__] bail you're done
because if you try for long enough and
you you give like that but if you're not
giving like that and then you're not
getting back either well I'm not
surprised you know that's how you end up
in my office is this death spiral of
everyone like well I'm not giving behind
the granola she's not giving me [__]
well I'm not giving him [__] he's
mean to me okay well everybody's just
gonna has an equal right to be [__]
miserable then
I think if you're happy with yourself be
truly happy with who you are at that
point in your life or whatever the
situation is I think it's easier for you
to
be happy with your partner yeah but I
would argue that
as long as you're not happy with
yourself
having someone happy with you is
certainly not gonna hurt your feeling of
who you are right like I don't
I I I don't need someone to tell me I'm
handsome for me to have a nice day but I
can't think of anybody telling me I was
handsome that it ruined my day you know
most of the time and you're like oh
that's nice you know I got that going
for me like it so yeah I think self-love
of course is the most important love and
to be secure in who you are and to not
allow your self-definition to be easily
swayed or pulled like if you believe the
good reviews you got to believe the bad
ones too I get that but I just don't
think kindness like it's just such an
easy especially if it's easy like it's
easy stuff like just telling someone
that they're beautiful or handsome or
that you're cheering for like it just to
me with marriage or pair bonds I
shouldn't even say marriage like the
world is trying to kill you all the time
you know like people are criticizing you
all the time you feel like a failure a
lot of the time if you compare yourself
to other people you'll constantly be you
know comparisons the thief of Joy so why
not have like one person who's just
cheering for you you know like
constructive criticism is criticism it's
still just criticism so if your spouse
is just sitting around criticizing you
and telling you all the things you could
do to improve yourself instead of just
being a fan and just saying you know
what I I I know who you are and you're
beautiful I know who you are and your
your heart is good and betting on the
best parts of a person I I think that
there's no there's very little downside
to that you know I think it'd put guys
like me out of this Business If people
really leverage that the right way I
asked you earlier if you believe in love
but you said you do do you believe in
marriage
I mean I believe people believe in
marriage yeah do I believe in marriage I
don't I don't think it's a useful
technology I I understand culturally why
people do it but I don't think people
should need it I I know I certainly
don't need marriage I don't think
marriage I was married
um I I was married before I really ever
thought about what does that mean you
know I married my college sweetheart you
know I I hadn't I got married because
that's what you do you get married you
know
um but I hadn't thought about it as a
technology and why it's there I didn't I
didn't understand it the way I do now
you know there's a line from a Joseph
Brodsky poem that he wrote when his wife
died where he says I wish I knew no
astronomy when stars appear
and I feel that way as a divorce lawyer
like I wish I knew no astronomy when
stars appear I wish I I wish I didn't
know what the end of so many marriages
looks like because I think I would have
a more optimistic and unrealistic view
of it I would yeah but you'd be divorced
and giving away half years I'd be
foolish yeah I'd be fool I'd be as
foolish but I don't know that I don't
know that it's always good to know right
sometimes there's tremendous joy to be
had and like falling feels like flying
for a little while you know so you hit
the ground it feels really good but as I
said earlier you know now that the life
expectancy of man is around the 80s or
something yeah then it's like so you're
going to do this from your 20s or 30s
until yeah well marriage is a technology
that was designed for when women died in
childbirth and when men died in their
40s if they were lucky you know 50s if
they were super lucky like if you were
in your 50s or 60s you were an elder you
know that was pretty amazing and women
most women died in childbirth like
childbirth is traumatic it's a traumatic
thing and before modern medicine and
before we understood antibiotics so
marriages is
um I don't think anyone ever planned
that that it was going to be okay we're
gonna do this forever you know we're
going to do this till we're in our you
know till we're a hundred I mean but I
think that's part of a bigger problem
you know I I don't remember who said it
but I remember someone saying I can't
remember who it was but we are
we are
prehistoric creatures right like we are
we are biological creatures
living in medieval institutions
like education work really with god-like
technology
how do you think that ends like you you
think that ends in happily ever after
like that's insane like marriage was not
design I mean think about even the early
days of marriage think about every
Rogers and Hammerstein musical you know
think about Oklahoma you know where
you'd have like there's like the three
people in town that aren't married you
know and and you sort of pick which of
the three you know you were gonna go be
with
and now you you have access to just an
endless supply of the opposite sex or or
I shouldn't even say the opposite sex
you have an endless supply of romantic
Partners in in a device in your hand how
how does that possibly stand up how does
marriage the idea of monogamy forced
monogamy or enforced monogamy how does
that ever survive in in that environment
I I don't think it can I don't think
it's realistic
um and and I'm I the statistics prove me
right
you know the statistics are absolutely
in my favor now again
get married as many times as you want if
you have a prenup if you have a prenup
go get married get married it's a blast
being married is difficult you know
someone once said that that it's great
to be married sometimes the problem is
you're married all the time so you're a
fan of prenups I'm a huge fan of prenups
I mean I shouldn't be because a prenup
for a couple of thousand dollars will
save you hundreds of thousands of
dollars potentially in legal fees if not
Millions so there are clients I have
that have spent over a million dollars
just in their legal fees that if they
had spent two thousand dollars on a
prenup
we would none of that they'd still have
that money in their pocket and that's
incredible to me like I have two sons
who are adults that they are absolutely
gonna have prenups like they have to
have prenups they'd be fools to not have
prenups it's like jumping out of a plane
with no parachute why would you do that
you know it's just it's stupid prenups
are enforceable they make sense I
actually think there's something very
romantic about prenups because they're
forcing you to have a conversation
about this relationship like we I
genuinely believe that we are the most
aware of our health
just after we got sick right like when
we if you wake up and you have a
toothache all you can think about is the
fact your tooth hurts
and then your toothache goes away and
for like a week you're taking care of
your teeth you go oh my God at least I
don't have a toothache you know but then
a month goes by and you don't wake up
and go at least I don't have a toothache
you know it's the furthest thing from
your mind
but theoretically you could wake up
today and go I don't have a toothache I
don't have a backache I don't have a
head cold like this is a great day it
was a typical prenup look like
typical the easiest prenup in the world
easiest yours mine ours that's it yours
mine ours if in your name it's yours if
it's in my name if it's mine in a
divorce everything all the assets are
split 50 50. well no what you say in a
prenuptial agreement is if it's an asset
or a liability if it's in my name it's
mine if it's in your name it's yours if
it's in our joint names we'll divide it
50 50. that's it yours mine ours and
then you have to have ongoing
conversations throughout the marriage
about
you know hey I got this bonus at work do
I put it in my account do I put it in
the joining if the husband owns a house
that's worth whatever two million
dollars and he marries a woman
the house is his still well they have to
have a conversation do I owe you a house
that's an awkward conversation do okay
you know what's a more awkward
conversation a conversation 10 years
later with a lawyer about the fact that
you have to give half of this house away
to someone isn't it better to have that
conversation when you still like why why
would you learn how to fight in a fight
but won't that undermine
the love that each person feels like why
you're gonna die does that undermine
your life or does it make you conscious
of the fact that this is finite and that
you should be out there like I think
having a conversation with your partner
about look I love you you love me we
want to do this thing together but the
numbers are against us and the world is
antagonistic to it and I hope we'll be
together forever but if we split up what
do we owe each other
what do you expect from me because I
have to tell you something I'm a fair
person I'm a fair person if you say to
me you know Jim
I I if I'm not going to work as hard
because you make a good living so if we
split up I'm gonna need help for a
couple of years because I'm not gonna
pay attention to my career okay does
that is that unreasonable that's totally
reasonable you know if I say Hey listen
I have this house and I bought it you
know but I'm buying it with money that I
made really before we were together so
if we split up I don't really think you
deserve half of it I think that if we
bought things for it together that okay
those things you can half of but the
house itself like that's money I had
before I met you and why can't you have
that conversation why not you instead I
mean you buy a house
you do a HUD one a lead paint disclosure
you gotta sign all these things that's
this is how much the interest is going
to be and this is what you get married
and get a [__] pamphlet you don't get
anything you just did the most legally
significant thing you're ever gonna do
other than die and no one has explained
any of it to you people come into my
office and they go well my retirement
account that's in my name and I'm like
yeah it doesn't matter it's in your name
okay was it acquired during the marriage
okay she's got half of it well I have
this bank account but it's in my sole
name it's money that I inherited from my
mom I'm like okay and it's in your name
yeah but you inherited that money during
the marriage and did you put money that
you earned during the marriage in that
account also yeah okay that's co-mingled
and transmuted that's now marital
property
so they don't know that why because no
one tells them that when they're getting
married all they did you spend more time
talking about the cake than you do
talking about the fact that you just
opted out of the title system that's
gigantic you can't legally change the
beneficiary of your life insurance even
to your children if you're married
without your spouse signing a consent to
that no one tells you that when you get
you can get married Elvis can marry you
for twenty dollars at a drive through
Cathedral
and you it's a legal status a massive
legal you buy your spouse a Rolex you
bought yourself one half of a Rolex you
buy someone a birthday present who
you're married to you bought them you
bought yourself one half of that
birthday present nobody know people
don't know that they learn that for the
first time in my office or in a
courtroom that's insane what what other
thing in the world like anything else
any other contract
you would say well wait a minute no one
explained that to me no one explained
that when I leased this car no one
explained to me that there's wear and
tear doesn't say it anywhere in the
contract right okay marriage contract
doesn't say that it doesn't say you know
oh and by the way you're opting out of
the title system and your retirement
assets and all these other things and if
there's any debts and you could have
enhanced earning capacity or celebrity
Goodwill that has to be valued by
forensic accountants that'll cost you a
hundred thousand dollars you don't no
contract that says that it just says yep
we're getting married it's two witnesses
we're good like what other contract what
other contract in the United States or
anywhere has that lack of disclosure and
is that binding none zero none
so why a prenup yes that's an awkward
conversation I guess I don't know that
it has to be and I have to tell you the
more Awkward of a conversation it is the
more you should think twice about
getting married
because
if you can't have a conversation with
this person
about the possibility that someday one
or both of you might hurt each other
like
how many people while they're still
happy and in love
say something like
you know babe I love you
but we're going to disagree about
something at some point
and when we do
how how do you like to fight like do you
need a minute
like do you need like to be alone for a
minute so you can kind of calm down or
are you the like hey we gotta figure
this out we can't go to bed angry like
because let's talk about that now while
we're not in the fight like let's talk
about it now while we well we still get
along and we're happy and we're trying
to figure out how to navigate each other
it's hard enough to navigate yourself I
want to navigate another human being why
don't we have that conversation now but
no we don't we learn on the job we learn
how to fight in a fight which is insane
you know but but again why because it's
you know it's awkward it'd be awkward to
have that conversation more Awkward than
getting in a fight where you don't know
the rules of engagement where you don't
know how your partner does better or
would feel better like and you're not
going to ask them that In the Heat of
battle you know so why wouldn't you have
that awkward conversation while you have
this abundance of affection for each
other I mean when I negotiate prenups
it's the easiest thing in the world in a
sense because these two people really
like each other
you know they're about to get married so
they're clearly not trying to kill each
other at that point they clearly like
each other so you just say Hey listen go
home talk to your fiance about X Y and Z
and see what they you know see what they
think and see tell them what your
concern is and and very often people
will come back and say to me I mean I
have to tell you I've been doing this
now you know over 20 years
I do a lot of prenups I do maybe
five six prenups a month sometimes
during like pre-wedding season which is
the fall and before the summer I'll do
10 15 a month
the people who say to me
oh well I I don't want to have that
conversation you know I think that they
they get the prenup and within three
four years they're divorced sometimes
five years and then seven years but
they're the ones who get divorced they
they have no business getting married
like the ones who
have the discussion and figure out the
well I'm worried because if you keep the
place yeah you're right okay so what if
I give you this amount of money and it's
this much for each year okay yeah that's
cool let's do it that way those people
they'll probably never gonna put the
prenup in a safe someplace you'll never
look at it probably good communication
ah because they're able to talk to each
other and they're able to talk about
hard things how are you going to be
married to someone
have children with someone and you can't
talk about hard things
you know like how how are you going to
navigate life and not be able to talk
about hard things like that's silly so
if you can't talk about hard things
don't get [__] married it's okay you
don't have to you can stay together but
but people love I had a client no joke I
was in his 70s he was married who's
married four times I did his third and
fourth divorces and he was getting
married for a fifth time
and I said to him I was like you because
I actually thought he's older
so I thought like does he know you don't
have to marry them anymore like this
maybe he doesn't know yeah maybe someone
didn't tell him like maybe someone
didn't tell him like you can [__] them
you don't have to marry them anymore you
can just do that he's dividing his asset
multiple times well it's I mean it's
getting smaller and smaller every time
but I said to him I was like why are you
doing this again
I was like you you don't have to get
married like you're clearly not created
it you know like and he was very funny
he said um he said you know Jim he said
you buy a car
and you drive it for 200 000 miles and
eventually the engine craps out so you
go out and you buy a Ferrari or you buy
some flashy sports car and you dry it
for a couple months you realize this is
not the car for me so you get rid of it
then you get another car and you know
you think this one's going to be the one
for you but you know after you drive it
for like a year you realize yeah this is
not the car for me you can lease them
instead of buying them you're gonna walk
everywhere for the rest of your life
yeah well that was my answer you could
lease them you could lease them or you
could you could have some other
alternative I mean here's the thing
about marriage is is it's a technology
so we made it up so we can change it
you think marriage will change in the
next 20 years no no I think it'll
I actually think it's going to have I
mean I think we're leaning I think the
pendulum always swings hard in the other
direction we have a we have a tendency
as a culture to over correct so I think
we're we're heading into a spiral of
like traditional stuff really like I
think you're gonna see like people
getting like super religious again
people are gonna get super dogmatic I
think we're gonna see the Trad wife
thing we're going to see the hyper
masculinity we're gonna see like a very
you know we've got to we've gone so far
in the direction of post-modernism where
nothing means anything and everything's
just you know like there is no definite
we become like sartra you know like
we've become so post-modern that it's
become almost a form of rugged
individualism I think we're going to
swing in the other direction now in
traditional institutions
it will be I mean you know from a
marriage place it's going to be great
because I think people are going to get
married I mean people were slowing down
on getting married for a while sure and
they were getting married later and
they're having kids later we're
declining to have kids and I think as we
I think as a culture we start
re-solidifying into gender roles or
gender tropes depending on how we're
going to look at it I think you're going
to see marriage resurge again
but I think that it's still going to be
as flawed of a technology As It Ever Was
and I think we have
so much out there now to compare
ourselves to you know you used to
compare yourself to the neighbors
next door and what car they had in the
driveway and what they were wearing when
they left for church on Sunday now
you're just looking at everyone's
greatest hits
while living your gag reel you know and
you're never
looking at any of that stuff when you're
having like a peak experience you're on
the toilet or you're bored and you're
looking at everyone's hashtag blast and
me while they're in my office like I
can't tell you how many people do a
consult with me and they're cheating and
they haven't slept with their spouse in
three years and they're miserable and
you're looking at their Instagram and
it's all like best life ever hashtag
greatest hubby ever and you're like what
is this it's performance art you know
it's an advertisement of how happy you
are but this is what people are
comparing themselves to they're looking
at that and going all my marriage isn't
that good that marriage isn't that good
trust me that marriage isn't that good
that marriage is in my look at
Celebrities you don't even look at the
people you know look at Celebrities
they're before they do they it is with
great sadness that we advise that we're
going to be moving in separate
directions and consciously on coupling
and like that right before that it's
like oh no we're happy we're great we're
phenomenal you know we're we're we're
constantly advertising how wonderful our
relationships are while they're on fire
you know and then wondering why
everyone's you know miserable in their
relationship because they're comparing
it to something fake it's like comparing
your your body to a photoshopped body
you know other than social media do you
think there's something else in our
society that made marriage more
difficult to
Stay Together
now makes it important and just like
your parents stayed married yeah my
parents stayed married until my mother
passed away same same with me um but
they were they were mixed results I see
I think that
my parents were not as
as
caught up in their own happiness
I think we're very caught up in our own
happiness we're all very selfish yeah
we're all very sort of I don't want to
say narcissistic but we're very much
like we are the sun around which
everything what am I not getting yeah my
father was a Vietnam veteran you know he
got out of the Naval Academy in 66 and
went to Vietnam for three years so he
was alive so he was like [__] I'm ahead
I'm playing with the houses of money I'm
alive everybody in their wedding party
all the men in their wedding party died
in Vietnam there's Five Guys in their
wedding party they all died in Vietnam
my parents never looked at their wedding
album because every single man and it
was dead they were all helicopter pilots
in Vietnam who got killed in their 20s
you know so they didn't really see
marriages like it was a partnership it
was like yeah we're gonna do this thing
we're gonna have kids we're gonna raise
the kids we're gonna you know we're
gonna have a house you know we're gonna
have a car like we'll be successful the
lights are on my father was dirt poor he
came from like Appalachian part of of of
Virginia a small town called Shawsville
didn't have indoor plumbing until they
left for the Naval Academy and he just I
think he saw marriages yeah it's what
you do you know he met my mom on fleet
week she was a nurse in the city and uh
he was you know on fleet week and he had
his uniform on and he was in a bar and
he was drunk and he he went to her and
and uh he said you're the most beautiful
woman I've ever seen and I'm gonna marry
you because he was drunk and she said um
are you in the military because he was
wearing a uniform and he said yep and
she said what country and he said
whatever country you're from
and he invited her to visit him at the
Naval Academy a couple of weeks later
and she came but he'd invited three
other women
he just didn't know if any of them would
come so he invited all of them so my mom
got there and she saw these other women
and she said either I'm leaving or
they're all leaving
and he was like I kind of like her so he
made them all leave and they were yeah
they were married 50 plus years but you
know their marriage had challenges you
know he was an alcoholic he's been in
recovery for maybe seven eight years
since she passed but
um and and he's remarried but he
remarried within a year of my mom dying
like he was the kind of he's of a
generation of men that he needed someone
to take care of him you know my mom died
he didn't even know how to scramble an
egg like it was you know like after she
passed I had him come to stay with me
and my sons and I was trying to like
teach him like okay dad here's how you
make like a batch of chili and then you
can eat it all week you know and and I
was like how's this guy gonna because
they had this very you know but that's
what I met another older woman and
her husband had died she needed someone
to take care of he needed someone to
take care of him but that generation
didn't have it as easy as we that's what
I'm saying like they they were just
reading your basic needs right they were
grateful to be alive they were grateful
to be alive because they'd either been
through War we're not grateful unless
we're driving a Mercedes or uh and even
then we're not grateful because because
the truth is as well okay Mercedes for
Mercedes who cares you know when people
have a Mercedes my secretary has a
Mercedes she leases it you know I drive
a Jeep so is she better than me is she
more successful than me she works for me
you know so I I don't I don't know that
any of it's enough anymore like no
matter what watch you have somebody's
got another one or a better one or five
of them and all this comparison that we
see it's all and and so I just think
that's the thing that makes it
impossible right like if if if you're
our parents generation was struggling to
just make it through right to to meet
your basic needs to keep a roof over
your head to raise your children and now
it's very much are you self-actualized
are you happy do you have eight pack at
like it would never have occurred to my
father did he have an eight pack
I would never have been something he
thought of you know it's just not it
just wasn't on his radar you know and I
don't think my mother would have ever
been like oh you know he he doesn't have
an eight pack like that wouldn't because
again though it's not constantly being
advertised to him you know I think that
how many women did he interact with in a
day you know how many women do I
interact with in a day visually or
personally in some fashion or or you
know in a curated mediated way and again
those are curated women by the way so
they're photoshopped they're airbrushed
they're they've got filters on them so
again you know I I how does marriage
survive in that setting it had a hard
enough time surviving without all of
that I mean forget kids the divorce rate
keeps increasing right yeah it keeps
going up it keeps going up it's it's
been hanging around 53 to 56 for a while
we had a bump after covet what are other
countries like
um countries that have a significant
religious narrative have the lowest
divorce rates so the lowest divorce
rates are in like you know
Saudi Arabia yeah but they don't have a
whole lot of choice right you're not
allowed to divorce or you just have your
wife killed you know so that that's you
don't have to divorce
um so the countries where there is this
very strict religious prohibition
against marriage or against divorce but
I mean the United States is probably the
highest divorce rate uh we're among the
highest yeah yeah I don't think we're
the hot we might we might be the highest
now
for a while Germany had a very high
divorce rate France had a pretty high
divorce rate
what's interesting is is the divorce
rate and the marriage satisfaction rates
those are different because most people
the goal is not can we stay married the
goal is can we stay happily married you
know because if somebody said to me like
yeah I've been married 25 years and I've
been [__] miserable for 15 of them
like I'm not going to envy you like
great job really hung in there in that
awful situation you know like that
that's not impressive to me you know I
have a cousin who got married and I was
I was chatting with her she's a younger
woman and I S her she her her husband uh
just joined the police force and I said
to him so I was trying to make small
talk and I said so do you you know do
you like it and he's from a family cops
and he said not not really but you know
I'm gonna do like the 20 years and then
you know you get your pension I thought
I'll just do my 20 that's 20 years
you're 25 years old that's 25 to 45.
those are [__] incredible Years
you'll never get those back and your
approach to life is yeah I mean I don't
like it but I'll just kind of do it you
know like I've I want to tiptoe through
life and arrive safely at death like
that seems you know but I I get that
that's what we're
if that's what marriage is if it's an
endurance event you know where no no
you've got to stay married you know why
I mean that's why I think
religions have been very quick to I mean
I always tell people I'm not religious I
was raised very Catholic
but the reality is that that you know I
mean there's if if in fact God talked to
humanity with Ten Commandments
I think it's hilarious that the only
thing he has to say twice is don't [__]
people you're not married to thou shall
not kill once right honor the Sabbath
once
don't covet your neighbor's wife don't
commit adultery it's it's the only thing
it's the only thing that got two
commandments so like basically don't
kill honor the Sabbath don't [__] people
you're not married to seriously don't
[__] people you're not married to like
there's no it didn't shall not steal one
you know everything it's the only one
that got double billing no religion's a
big component and it's a huge component
but why because how else are you going
to control people how else are you going
to get people to sign on for this thing
and not sleep with each other I mean I'm
not saying Freud was right but we we do
want to sleep with people we do want to
kill people that don't do what we want
them to do like we have these animal
instincts we have these impulses and
what do we do with them well we have to
live in a civilized society so
civilization it's discontent we have to
marry certain that marriage was outlawed
or just abolished it would just be a
free-for-all I don't know that that's
true I mean I think that I think people
would like us to believe that's true you
know I I don't believe that like I don't
believe
if murder wasn't illegal that I would
just go killing people like I like you
know like I I rape and murder as many
people as I want to which is none
because I'm not a monster like I don't I
rape as many people as I Want To None
because I don't want to I wouldn't want
to do that to another person I think I
think society would be probably happier
without marriage well I think we would
have a lot less of the damage that comes
right I think we'd have to find new
narratives
to structure
to Define relationships right I mean I
do think there is a part of us that
wants to say
because you know I I as a grown man
who's divorced
when you're when you're 20 and you say
oh that's my girlfriend nobody thinks
any of it when you're 50 and you say oh
that's my girlfriend people go there's a
story there like because you're either
divorced or commitment phobic or why do
you have a girlfriend when you're 50 why
isn't that your wife
so they know there's a story there so
we'd have to and I get it I get it
because if if someone says oh that's my
boyfriend it's like all right well that
could be for a week that could have been
nothing they could be like yeah it's my
boyfriend my husband it's like oh okay
wait that's that's there that's her
husband like she's got some Authority
there so I get that there's this idea
that we want to say like you know it's
like when you're a little kid this is my
friend but this is my best friend
you know this is my best friend but like
how many adults
still need to say that like how many
adults still need to say oh my friend
Todd and I and my best friend Tom and I
like
okay like so the extra special friend
like like what are they these are like
do they get health insurance with that
like what is the deal with that so I
think that's kind of what marriage has
become is it's like you know well the
person I love no no but like the person
I love like there's a lot of people I
love I wouldn't want to be married to
any of them but there's a lot of people
I love you know and and I love my
ex-wife I wouldn't want to be married to
her I think she loves me she wouldn't
want to be married to me I don't blame
her I'm a great ex-husband I'm a
terrible husband I'm a great ex-husband
because the skill set for an ex-husband
is totally different than skill set for
a husband skill set for a father is
completely different than that of a
husband that's the the thing I have to
tell people all the time all the time
people say well he's a terrible husband
so you shouldn't have custody of the
kids I'm like what the [__] where's the
overlap between being a good husband and
being a good father
like being a good father is a whole
different skill you can be a great
husband and a [__] father and you can be
an amazing father and terrible husband
like these there's very little overlap
in those skill sets you know maybe good
listening skills would be helpful in
both or patience would be good in both
but that's true of almost anything you
know it's a doctor and a lawyer both be
good if you had good listening skills it
doesn't mean they're the same profession
so is divorce harder on women or men
that's a great question
I think it's equally hard on both
but I think that the world is more
sympathetic to women when they get
divorced I think when a woman gets
cheated on
the man's a piece of [__]
and when a woman cheats on a man
she must have been forced into the arms
of this other man or she had to explore
herself or she was being neglected in
some fashion and so if if a man cheats
he's a piece of garbage and if a man's
wife cheats
he mustn't have been meeting her needs
and she had ever right in the world like
so the world is very unsympathetic to
men when they get divorced that's that's
been throughout Earth yeah that's been
for I mean there was a maternal
presumption a legal legal presumption
what was called the The Tender Years
Doctrine which was that if a child was
under the age of seven they were
automatically presumed that they would
be in the custody of the mother
um and men so men get really beat up
still in court I mean the loss
theoretically is gender blind right now
but I I don't I don't actually see that
because the law is people the law is
judges and judges are human and they're
they're all the same biases and and it's
just not a moment right now where men
are particularly sympathetic characters
you know I think that you know even even
young men I mean if you know if at a
school dance they sing Beyonce's girls
who runs the world like if there was a
song called men who runs the world men
and and it was a positive thing like you
get pilloried for that so I think that
men have a very hard time right now in
divorce they see their children less
they get hit harder financially
um they are the bad guy no matter what
if they cheat they're the bad guy if
they get cheated on they were the bad
guy because they probably neglected her
there's a presumption that the man is to
Blame A lot of the time now again you
know marriage equality has been a thing
for a while so there are you know tons
of gay couples so you have two men two
women divorcing each other
um and that hasn't really shook out too
much yet in terms of how that plays out
um I don't know if it's that gay and
lesbian couples are better at it than
heterosexual couples or if it's still
they're in the honeymoon period because
you know marriage equality hasn't been
around that long but I I think
men find a less sympathetic world but
In fairness
divorced men have it a little easier I
think divorced men
meet a young woman
and the woman's like instant family just
add me that's great you know if he's got
kids it's like oh he's got kids look at
his nurturing he is and how lovely and
women you know they get divorced they've
got kids guys are like whoop it's got
baggage I'm not going near that you know
so I think
I think they that men and women have
different problems post-divorce and and
the world could be better to both of
them I think that I have some women who
uh who you know I've done their divorce
and whatever guy is with them is going
to be very lucky because they're they're
beautiful they're smart they're good
moms but they're also you know vibrant
exciting women now they're loaded and
they've got money yeah yeah they've got
money they don't have as much Financial
insecurity although I have to tell you
that you know let's last remaining
feminist taboo I got a lot of women
paying alimony these days I mean you
know women can Women Marry the like
handsome musician who's not successful
or the artist you know like there's a
lot of listen it hasn't been you know
there's been a significant effort in in
our culture in the last decade if anyone
didn't notice to improve the situation
of women if you have an equally
qualified man an uniquely qualified
woman the woman's diversity hire the
man's not so I have a lot of women who
get when they get told like oh yeah no
you got to give him half your [__] or oh
no you got to pay alimony because he
makes 50 Grand a year and you make 250.
and they're like you know they could be
the staunchest feminist in the world and
when you tell them they got to pay
alimony they're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa he's a man he's got a strong back
he can get out there and work and and
then suddenly the whole like gender is a
construct and there's no such thing that
goes right out the window and you got
told you got to pay alimony that's like
nope no no no I believe in strict gender
roles men should pay alimony women even
if you earn 10 times you should not have
to pay alimony I've had I've had very
very staunchly feminist clients who who
changed their mind about how feminist
they were when they got told that they
were going to have to pay alimony
interesting yeah and but I do have a lot
of men who won't take alimony even
though they're entitled to it because
there's just some feeling of like yeah
no I'm not doing that it's emasculating
like if she tells people that we know
that I took alimony from her like people
think I'm less than a man so again it's
all gender stuff it's still out there
it's still still part of the Zeitgeist
you know we're still trying to figure it
all out how many how many marriages are
genuinely happy you think
how many married couples
gosh
because I see married couples that have
been married it looks like they've been
married a decade or two yeah and they're
having dinner and they're having the
same conversation they had yesterday the
day before the day before that in the
weeks and months before that yeah you
know here's what I'll tell you I I have
I know a lot of people and I I think I
know one couple
that has like a genuinely happy marriage
what do you think the secret is
ah they really like each other I don't
know like they're really good to each
other
I have to tell you they make me very
uncomfortable
I I jokingly my my ex-wife and I
jokingly say that they were the reason
we got divorced
because we we have we've known them
since we were in college
and we went to Disney with them with
their kids and our kids when all the
kids were little
and we were gonna go on a ride with our
kids and their kids and they they were
gonna like you know oh like we'll take
the kids on the ride and you guys can go
and my friend was like oh good we're
just gonna go walk and hold hands
and they walked away and like holding
hands and we looked at them and we
didn't say anything to each other but
like five years later when we got
divorced I said you know I when I saw
the two of them together
I thought I don't feel like that about
her
like and she said oh my God I remember
that exact moment I felt the same way so
I think they make people uncomfortable
like when you see someone who's got it
right like this guy just loves her he
loves her they've been married 25 years
and dude he's like it's like he's
talking about a girl he met yesterday
and and she's the same way about him
like she's a miracle when that happens
yeah I just think it look you know man I
tell people marriage is like the lottery
you are probably not going to win
you know but but but if you win what you
win is so good like I don't know maybe
you buy a ticket [__] it like but buy it
to get a prenup like do you do you take
all your money and buy lottery tickets
no but if you and I don't buy lottery
tickets like I don't play the lottery
you're not gonna [__] win why you
know set the money on fire it'll be more
fun but if somebody said to me no man
you know what once a week I buy twenty
dollars worth of lottery tickets all
right go for it you know Somebody's
gotta win maybe it'll be you like same
thing with marriage like somebody's got
to win like yeah I've met hundreds if
not thousands of couples and I know one
one that is legitimately happy and like
really seemed to just feed that
happiness by that marriage that they
have and and they both as individuals
have become the best version of
themselves by being you know what like
if that's they won the lottery so buy
the ticket I guess you know but I mean
don't don't make that your retirement
plan like don't go like well you know
don't worry I'm not saving money for my
kids college because you know I'm buying
lottery tickets like that's you're an
idiot if you're doing that
excellent Jim thank you so much for
sharing your story it's a pleasure your
thoughts on marriage and love and
divorce fascinating topic isn't it yeah
it is and I suspect it will continue to
be I I don't know that we're going to
culturally get any better at it but uh
the economy is good we're busy economy's
bad we're busy like we're we're a
recession-proof industry so you know
it's it's uh even even kova didn't slow
us down you know probably sped you up
well people said for better for worse
they didn't say for lunch you know and
when you're locked in the house together
it was that was not great for most
marriages like there was no no uh it was
not hey we should all spend more time
together you know there was there was a
lot of difficult conversations that came
out of that Barbers and divorce lawyers
when the pandemic ended we were the
lines were out the door you know so
whatever the next thing is you know
we'll we'll still be here all right
thank you so much you got it man